bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 7 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale accompagnés des
journalistes de la rédaction mais
également de nos invités
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition les élections
régionales valérie pécresse largement en
tête dans les yvelines elle totalise 30
7,2 pour cent des voix ces 7 % de plus
que dans l'ensemble de la région
les principaux résultats de ce premier
tour des régionales dans un instant
retour sur la 29e édition du téléthon
compteur relativement stables pour les
dons en france malgré les événements du
13 novembre dernier certaines communes
bat néanmoins leurs records c'est le cas
de magny les hameaux
daniel tamam son orgue coordinateur et
l'inviter chez du journal et puis en
culture notre chronique du lundi
consacré au festival versailles au son
des orgues un patrimoine qui a fait la
richesse de la cité royale est dans
l'actualité nous revenons bien
évidemment sur le premier tour des
élections régionales qui a eu lieu hier
en ile-de-france valérie pécresse
candidate les républicains arrive en
tête de ce premier tour avec 30 51 % des
voix claude bartolone le candidat
socialiste atteint les 25,19 % quant à
20 les rangs de saint-just tête liste du
front national
il obtient 18,41 % des suffrages sur le
territoire ile de france
le deuxième plus mauvais score pour le
front national après la région bretagne
quant au taux d'abstention il est de
54,11 % et le point sur le département à
présent la candidate député yvelinoise
est également en tête avec un score de
37,23 % le deuxième meilleur score de la
région ile de france après celui qu'elle
a réalisés dans le département des
hauts-de-seine
l'écart avec le président du perchoir
est plus notable dans les yvelines
le candidat socialiste arrive également
en deuxième position mais avec 21 points
52% des suffrages exprimés le candidat
fn obtient 19 j'annule 0 5% des voix
dans les yvelines
abstention et de 51,81 2% enfin pour la
candidate les républicains c'est un
score en demi teinte pour l'île de
france car elle était créditée de 33%
d'intentions de vote dans les derniers
sondages notamment au vu de son alliance
avec le modem et lui dit on les écoute
tout de suite elle est cette prime et
hier soir rue de turin à paris à côté du
quartier général des républicains juste
après l'annoncé des résultats écouter et
à ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour la liste
que je conduis je veux dire que j'ai
entendu votre colère je sais que vous
avez perdu confiance dans la politique
vous attendez beaucoup plus de vos élus
plus de sécurité mais aussi plus
d'espoir plus d'engagement plus de
conviction plus d'honnêteté
ce que je vous propose ce sont des
solutions concrètes pour obtenir enfin
des résultats chômage record territoires
abandonnés transport saturé logement
inabordable famille oublier pollution
insécurité personne ne peut prétendre
résoudre vos problèmes sans s'investir à
temps plein moi je ne cumulerait pas je
renoncerai à tout autre mandat pour être
président de la région à 100% et tout de
suite après le journal plus de résultats
et d'analysé avec wilfrid est réussi
pour un 7 8 politiques spéciales
résultats des premier tour des élections
régionales et à présent nous allons
revenir sur l'édition 2015 du téléthon
avec nous en plateau daniel tamam
coordinateur des objectifs payer
téléthon à magny les hameaux bonsoir à
vous et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors ses bénéfices sous
moindre que l'année dernière mais il
continue à mobiliser massivement les
français avec plus de 80 millions
d'euros récoltés cette année le téléthon
2015 a tiré tout de même les foules ce
week-end malgré les événements du 13
novembre dernier dans les yvelines la
mobilisation pour la manifestation était
moins conséquent que les années
précédentes mais les promesses de dons
était tout de même au rendez vous nous y
reviendrons avec vous dans quelques
instants juste après ce reportage signé
william el est patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est une cause qui tient à coeur au
français chaque année le téléthon cet
immense collecte pour la recherche
notamment en faveur des maladies rares a
engrangé environ 80 millions d'euros de
recettes cette année et pour rassembler
tous les moyens sont bons dans la ville
de magny les hameaux on a choisi de
hisser le drapeau noir
l'objectif vasselle de récolter le plus
possible de fonds pour au profit du
téléthon c'est vraiment l'objectif donc
on est tous des bénévoles souvent nos
activités sont sans fait avec nos
propres moyens on investit nous mêmes
c'est important de tu de continuer de ne
pas s'arrêter au milieu du lien et
d'avoir de donner l'impulsion pour avoir
les résultats contre et d'avoir les
mises sur le marché qui permettront de
soigner plus de 19000 euros ont été
récoltés à magny les hameaux ses 2000 de
plus que l'année dernière
globalement dans les yvelines les dons
étaient en hausse à montigny le
bretonneux le soleil du téléthon
rayonner aussi sur le vélodrome ce
cycliste jean michel richefort a réalisé
l'exploit de courir pendant 24 heures
réunissant de nombreux sponsors
permettant la collecte de 7400 euros
concerts et spectacles étaient également
au programme pour animer ces 30 heures
de marathon solidaire dans un vélodrome
qui a eu du mal à se remplir
il ya aussi les derniers accidents qui
ont eu il ya pas longtemps donc je pense
que ça a eu un
on peut déjà une mais la trop grosse et
seulement sur balmoral un peu les jambes
et le fait que les gens s'en moquent de
moi ça a un impact sur la beta donc je
pense que c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya
énormément aujourd'hui on est là quand
même pour représenter un impact
significatif sur la mobilisation
physique qui s'est répercuté sur les
recettes de certaines manifestations
néanmoins les dons par téléphone ont
toujours du succès 81 millions c'est 10
de moins que l'année précédente
et rappelons que sur cette somme 80 %
sera reversée directement aux chercheurs
pour lutter contre la maladie alors je
le rappelle le téléthon permet de
collecter des dons en faveur de la
recherche très active sur les maladies
rares qui sont entre 6000 et 8000 et
touche en france quelques 3 millions de
personnes alors on l'avait un reportage
le téléthon c'est plutôt bien à passer
pour vous vous avez été plus impacté par
les événements du 13 mai dernier des
attentats de paris
effectivement bien passé à magny les
hameaux
je ne sais pas s'il ya eu un gros impact
des événements du mois précédent
je crois surtout que lémanique ou à
leurs amis leurs familles se savent se
mobiliser ils le font depuis des années
depuis toujours ils l'ont fait une fois
de plus il aurait fait autrement s'il
est ici a pas eu de soucis le mois
dernier donc vous allez récolter plus
clair
oui 14% de plus que les dernières aubry
la clé du succès en fait c'est celle que
l'on mette en place depuis depuis des
années c'est des activités c'est un fil
rouge des activités novatrices
chaque année et puis surtout attiré
attirer les gens d'en bas
tout se passe dans un gymnase avec une
succession de spectacles de choses à
voir des choses à me ranger ses il ya
une solidarité spécifique dans les
yvelines ajustements par rapport au
téléthon peut-être la manière dans les
yvelines certainement à magny les
hameaux sur moi oui sur vous les manies
qu à son généreux naturellement ils
savent se mobiliser
ça c'est certain quelle que soit la
raison et puis son généreux vous avez eu
d'ailleurs des reportages il ya dix ans
un coeur gros comme ça
comment on fait justement pour réussir à
mobiliser les gens d'années en années
souhaitées répond pour voilà affaire qui
est encore plus de dons c'est compliqué
justement mettre en place ce genre
d'événement s'est pas particulièrement
compliqué non non il faut chaud mettre
en place une succession de d'activité de
plaisir avant tout c'est festif et puis
on profite de ce moment festif pour
transmettre des messages forts pourquoi
ils sont là et là la raison de la
collecte et puis la destination des des
dons aussi et ses messages ils sont
entendus par les plus jeunes et pas
réparé par l'ensemble des personnes qui
viennent nous voir alors justement sur
un peu début du téléthon sur balles à la
recherche dont vous informer les gens
qu'on vous leur dites explique cement
vos dons vont servir à ça parce que
parfois c'est un petit peu obscur pour
certaines personnes bien sûr alors en
amont communique beaucoup par tous les
médias qui nous sont offertes et puis
durant une trentaine d'heures
on sans cesse on rappelle que
destination des dons qui sont réalisés
il ya de plus en plus de médias qui sont
parfois découvrent qu'ils sont
découvertes est ce que du coup sûr vous
vous avez des années ou spécifiques vous
vous attachez peut-être à une autre m'a
dit non non non non on s'attache à la
recherche alimenté la recherche avant
tout mais par rapport à je sais pas les
les événements parce que nation à ma
nissan a pas touchées mais c'est de les
événements de paris les attentats ont
touché un petit peu plus nationalement
il ya eu peut-être un ou deux millions
de moins à ce que ça va impacter
nationalement justement la recherche par
rapport au téléthon je ne le pense pas
les français sont sont généreux ils se
sentent concernés on vous l'avait dit
1,3 million de 3 millions de français
potentiellement concernées par la
maladie par les maladies génétiques
rares
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient un gros
impact au niveau national tous les cas
chez nous il y en a pas comme on fait
justement si on veut continuer à aider à
la fm tout en l'année alors il ya le 36
37 qui permet de collecter c'est la
télématique et puis il peut y avoir tout
le tout au long de l'année des activités
qui sont proposées dans le cadre du
téléthon donc à partir du début janvier
ça sera pour le téléthon besoin 2007
voilà une vérité à temps ce n'est pas
qu'une fois par an c'est toute l'année
je le rappelle en plus des 230 programme
de recherche l'association soutient
cette année 37 essais thérapeutiques aux
cours en cours développement sur une
trentaine de maladies du sang du cerveau
des muscles du foie de la vue et du
coeur merci beaucoup daniel quand même
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
nous passons maintenant à la culture
comme chaque lundi vous en avez
l'habitude nous retrouvons à sephora
namani bonsoir sephora minceur le rêve
aujourd'hui nous ont parlé musique avec
la sixième édition de vercel où sont d
orgue exactement la sixième édition de
verseilles au son des hogues avait lieu
toute la semaine dernière et proposer
différents concerts d'orgue sur
versailles et visite découverte de
l'instrument
ce festival est organisé par
l'association des amis de l'orgue de
versailles et de la région qui a pour
but la promotion de l'instrument et la
diffusion de sa musique
nous avons rencontré jean pierre miou
président de l'association l'orque peut
apparaître comme un instrument assez
inaccessible dans la mesure où la porte
est fermée en bronze quelques fois
on s'imagine mal dans un instrument qui
commet la cathédrale vous présente
seulement que 98 ion qui en à 3248 en
tout il ya tout ce monde sonore à
découvrir et que vous verrez dans le
reportage donc oui il faut faire
connaître cet instrument qui évidemment
est le peut paraître inaccessible parce
qu'il est en hauteur quelquefois il faut
être wallach ans l'organiste est présent
pour pour le voir jouer le voir faire
des pieds et des mains
alors va pour gagner un tel festival /
marseille je suppose qu'il n'y a donc
beaucoup d'orgue dans la ville
oui ça appartient vraiment au patrimoine
versailles et on peut en dénombrer 19
alors le plus ancien qui est d'ailleurs
grandes orgues historiques date de 10
761 il a été commandé sous louis 15
élite dans la cathédrale saint-louis
c'est celui que j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir visiter et pourquoi l'appel tant
le grand tort historique alors tout
simplement parce qu'il appartient
pleinement en fait à l'histoire de
france car le 4 mai 1789 il accueillit
la procession des états généraux est
animée et commentée la messe et quelques
temps après la clé la seconde
proclamation du serment du jeu de paume
ce qui l'a sauvé parce que grâce à ça il
a été épargnée pendant la révolution
française est classé grandes orgues
historiques et puis donc le dernier venu
sur versailles a été installée à
l'église sainte jeanne d'arc qui
provient du studio sont rois de la
maison de radio france et de quand date
alors le premier orgue
alors écoutez le premier orgue date de
2300 ans les été inventé par un grec
d'alexandrie nommé pays bios il faut
savoir que l'instrument n'a pas toujours
accompagné la liturgie des églises car
l'orgue appartenait au grand cirque de
rome pendant le martyre des premiers
chrétiens au 1er siècle après
jésus-christ et c'est seulement au 10ème
siècle que l'orgue apparaît à l'église
quand l'empereur théodose de
constantinople en fait cadeau à pépin le
bref qui ne sachant pas quoi en faire le
laisse dans une église à compiègne c'est
en s'apercevant qu'ils pouvaient
accompagner un choeur de moines ou une
assemblée en prière qui chantait que
l'instrument permettait de ne pas
baisser
au contraire ils pouvaient ensuite
dialoguer et puis répondre avec l'éclat
qu'on lui connaît ou
contraire le côté très doux que vous
avez plus en entendre aussi c'est vrai
que nous avons à notre disposition nous
les organistes une puissance qui varie
du du pianissimo le plus le plus doux le
plus discret jusqu au fortissimo
souverain alors donc depuis le 18è le
xème siècle l'orgue et devient
l'instrument cultuelle mais aussi
culturel il en existe des milliers en
france dont le plus grand qui se trouve
à notre dame de paris avec 8000 clio
appelé également des individus si on
veut être vraiment précis et enfin
sachez qu'il ya deux écoles de
manufacture d'orgues en france oui tout
à fait à peu près une dizaine de maisons
de facture d'orgue pour fabriquer
entretenir tous les orbes français
sachant qu'un facteur d'orgue est en
capacité de couler la fonderie pour
créer les tuyaux de l'orgue qui sont
constitués majoritairement en étain
déterminer leurs auteurs pour qu'il
sonne la bonne note et les harmoniser
il faut savoir que les orgues sont
entièrement monté en atelier pu démonter
remonter dans les églises ou cathédrale
pour indication l'orgue de la cathédrale
saint louis c'est plus de 12 mètres de
hauteur 10 mètres de largeur 3248 tuyaux
et 53 tonnes pour le fonctionnement de
ce pape des instruments comme aimait le
surnommer friendfeed je laisse la parole
à jean pierre miyuki le 14e organiste de
la cathédrale saint-louis de versailles
notre ingénieur tesi bios qui était fils
d'un coiffeur à alexandrie à 2300 ans a
conçu quelque chose qui fonctionne
encore c'est à dire une pompe à air
aujourd'hui nous avons un moto
ventilateurs électriques
cette pompe à l'aiea en voie de l'être
dans une entrée sous pression
naturellement desaulniers se trouve sous
une pluie yacht rit et on va ouvrir au
moyen d'une clé un clavier on va ouvrir
un système de deere qui va nous
permettre de faire parler ce tuyau
alors attention à ne pas confondre le
facteur d'orgues qui entretient et créer
l'instrument de l'organiste et le
musicien donc celui qui joue de
l'instrument il est question
prochainement de resterait d'ailleurs le
grand orgue de saint louis sont tout à
fait alors normalement la restauration a
lieu tous les 20 ans là ça fait 26 ans
monde
encore un peu parce que une restauration
c'est un démontage complet de toutes les
pièces et provoque en fait deux ans
d'inactivité pour l'instrument donc
sinon pour ceux qui n'auraient pas pu
profiter du festival il y aura un bis
avec un concert gorgue dimanche prochain
à 16 heures à l'église notre-dame de
versailles
et pour vous donner envie je vous
propose un extrait de récitals d'orgue
merci à cette fois on vous retrouve
mercredi pour un nouveau numéro de
kiosques l'intégralité des résultats
sportifs ce sera demain à 18h30 dans le
7-8 sport avec michael elle me d'euros
car c'est la fin de cette édition est
tout de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
wilfrid errishi pour un numéro spécial
du 7-8 petit donc spécialement dédié aux
élections régionales demain pas de
journal mais un débat lui aussi consacré
au second tour des élections régionales
quant à moi je vous retrouve donc
mercredi pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 le journal je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée